- [Instructor] The goal of
this video is to appreciate
some of the structures that you see
even in unicellular organisms.
So this right over here
is a picture of the amoeba
Chaos carolinense.
And what you see here is
a projection coming off
from the main part of the cell,
and this is called a pseudopod,
which is referring to
it being a false foot.
The pod is coming from the
same root word as podiatry,
which is referring to the foot.
And what I really want you to appreciate,
this is used by amoeba
either to move around
or it could be even
used to attack something
that it wants to engulf.
And think about what it might
take to be able to do this,
to be able to grow this
type of a pseudo foot,
this type of a false foot.
You need all sorts of
microstructures in here
that will extend or contract as necessary.
And think about the machinery
that you need to do that.
And so the key realization is,
sometimes we just imagine cells as these
bags of fluid with a few
things floating around.
But they're these incredibly
complex structures,
and biologists even today
don't fully understand
how everything works and they're studying
how these things actually come to be.
Now another structure
that you'll often see
in unicellular organisms that
either help them move around
or even help move other
things around are cilia.
So this right over here is a
picture of Oxytricha trifallax,
which is a unicellular organism.
It's a eukaryote.
And you can clearly see these projections
from its body here,
these hairlike structures.
Remember this is a unicellular organism.
If we were to, it's actually a fairly,
it's a decent sized one.
That would be about, something
like that would be about
30 micrometers right over there
or 30 millionths of a
meter or 30 thousandths
of a millimeter.
So small by our scale, but
it's actually pretty big
on the scale of it being a cell.
And once again, these cilia
tend to move in unison
to either allow the
microorganism to move around
or sometimes they're used
to move other things around.
For examples the cells
that line your lungs
will have cilia that
are used to move things
up or down, to move some of
the saliva or any particles
that are in there.
Now Oxytricha trifallax is
particularly interesting
as a eukaryote because it
doesn't just have one nucleus.
It can have two nuclei.
And within the nucleus,
it's DNA can be extremely fragmented.
Most organisms have
a reasonable number of chromosomes.
Human beings have 23 pair.
That's actually a fairly large number.
Oxytricha trifallax could
have thousands of chromosomes.
And what's really interesting
about Oxytricha trifallax
is how it mates.
When it is under stress,
it will merge with another
Oxytricha trifallax,
and instead of producing
another offspring,
they mingle their DNA together.
So by mating, they change
each other's genetic makeup,
which is fascinating.
And depending on your
perspective, highly romantic.
Now another related idea
is instead of having
many cilia, some unicellular
organisms will just have
one large thing that looks like a tail
that they can whip around to move.
So this right over here is a
commonly studied green algae.
It's called Chlamydomonas,
and you can see very
clearly here this flagellum,
this tail-like structure.
And this is extremely thin.
We're seeing it under a
very powerful microscope
right over here,
but just to get a sense of scale.
A micrometer here would be about that.
So the width of this flagellum,
flagellum would be the singular.
If we were talking about many of these,
we would say flagella.
This is about 1/4 of a micrometer.
Another way of thinking about it,
you could put 4,000 of these side by side,
and you would have the
width of a millimeter.
So extremely extremely small,
but once again, it really is amazing
that these what seem like
simple organisms to us
are actually quite complex.
There's a whole study of how
these flagella move around,
how the cell can spin it
around so it allows it to move.
If you were to actually
decompose what's going on
in this part of the cell,
it's actually quite complex.
It's biological machinery going on.
So once again, these
cells are not these just
bags of just a few things floating around.
They're incredibly complex structures
that we are still trying to understand.